la discussion de la réforme commence mal
elle est largement entravée par les
centaines d'irres solvabilité
qui frappent nos amendements cette loi
qui traite insuffisamment des questions
de travail via un simple index senior ne
peut pas être amandé en ce sens car
beaucoup des amendements permettant
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
la prise en compte des critères
pénibilité la redéfinissait
redéfinissions de certains seuils au
cœur des questions de pénibilité
d'inaptitude et donc de retraite ont été
déclarés irrecevables au titre qu'il ne
porterait pas sur une loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale mais alors c'est
que si ça ne ce qui ne traite pas des
financements de la sécurité sociale
c'est alors l'index senior auquel ces
amendements étaient rattachés et cet
article se trouve donc quasiment
inammandable c'est nouveau on nous
empêche aussi de demander des rapports
sur la décote ou de parler des caisses
de retraite dans une Loire et formant
les retraites certains amendements ont
été repris des P 2016 précédent qui
n'avait pas été déclaré ircevable comme
celui de la PCH qui avait figuré dans
les trois derniers pets projets de loi
on nous empêche également d'aborder
certains sujets sous l'ONDAM alors que
nous sommes sur un SS parit-il ou bien
nous sommes face à un PLFSS et dans ce
cas il faut le traiter comme tel ou bien
il faut d'ores et déjà pouvoir assumer
que le véhicule actuel n'est pas
approprié en toute est à cause la mère
des réformes devrait pouvoir nous faire
débattre des conséquences qu'elle aura
sur le travail la pénibilité le système
de soins les financiers et les recettes
par contre je note que des amendements
de dépenses de la droite sénatoriale
sont acceptés ah bah ça c'est un vrai
comble et oui c'est pourtant cela donc
c'est totalement vous commencez très mal
cette discussion et nous allons en tenir
compte